[Music]
hi my name's Dave Chang were at my
restaurant majordomo here in North
Chinatown Los Angeles the term ugly
delicious came about sort of as not as a
joke but something I think I've been
turning around with for many years that
good food could be really great even
though it doesn't look so pretty just
because something looks imperfect
doesn't mean that it's not perfect right
and it's really not only beauty and the
eye of the beholder but it's like who's
setting these standards quite frankly
the ugly delicious at its core though is
to sort of be accepting of many
different things and understanding that
multiple truths might be true and
ultimately know that there's a hidden
value in certain things right you may
not like it right off the bat but the
more you're patient with it the more you
understand it you might find it to be
more delicious than you originally
thought
Koreans called bread Fung Chinese call
it Bing so there's a lot of words in
China Japan Korea that have very similar
associations and having spent time and
traveled throughout those regions and
even a lot of bread I just thought well
this is wildly not misrepresented and I
think misunderstood if you look at this
you're gonna be like oh it's just like a
flatbread I think the next story for me
is like how do you make the flatbread
what is it similar to and like how do
you consume it because you could stuff
it you could just tear it off and dip it
in something I mean it's just bread man
it's griddle bread we're gonna make some
water and we're gonna put in some yeast
and flour you change the recipe with
some sugar sometimes some salt we're
gonna pour [ __ ] out probably like a
hundred grams bench it out proof it and
then roll it out again and then put it
on the griddle probably it's like 350
degrees and you're cooking it like a
pancake long story cut short it's just
really delicious and it allows us to
serve it with this thing called chickpea
hosana basically a chickpea dip but
we're not making it like traditional
hummus it's way more Asian if not
anything more Amer
can we ferment chickpeas with Koji which
is Aspergillus oryzae which is very
popular right now but is the engine that
drives much of I would say Japanese for
many Goods I'm mixing in lemon juice and
olive oil and some sesame oil maybe a
little girl and we garnish it with
sesame seeds and a little chili sesame
oil that's a super simple process but
it's actually very very hard to get
right I think with majordomo we wanted
to do something that was out of our
comfort zone a little bit I think
there's some obviously DNA from what
we've done in the past but we really
wanted to celebrate what it might mean
to be a Los Angeles restaurant and I
think for us we were trying to think if
this was our only restaurant what would
that look like and this is it so I think
it's a celebration of all things
California and I think if you look at
California cuisine today this really is
I think a continuation of what Wolfgang
said years ago which is like it's a
melting pot and our food here should
represent that three Michelin star
restaurants are fantastic but you
shouldn't only celebrate those
restaurants utterly delicious is
challenging conventional wisdom